you're returning to dancing with the
stars this fall as a judge so which is
harder is it harder being a pro dancer
there or a judge oh being a pro dancer
for sure being a judge is is kush i'm
not gonna lie yeah i'm like and now
dance please thank you
hours and hours on end and good nice you
know
so i appreciate that though because i
did 17 seasons yeah doing that and um
but uh i'm excited about this season
because len's gonna be back you know and
so there's gonna be four of us beyond
just yeah i'm trying to think where i'm
gonna sit i might just sit on his lap
and then you know please do what'd you
think liz think about that darling what
um would you ever go back and dance you
know i i'm i might you know i'll never
say never i love the show so much it's
so much fun
and it would have to be like the right
partner or the right
thing i don't know i don't wait well
who's the right partner
like who would be funded i've always
said i've always said like celine dion
because oh my god she i met her once one
couple times but the first time i met
her was on my first season of dancing
with the stars yeah she performed
and i was walking up the stairs i was
holding some shoes and she goes dare
cuff and i'm like
slaying down knows my name and then i
was like i i didn't know what to say so
i just said i'm holding shoes
and she said she's like derek huff is
holding shoes oh yeah
and then she just started seeing a turn
and then walked away and i was like
the hell just happened what you just got
serenaded by celine i did and then later
you know further down the line i met her
and then uh she was telling me she goes
i love dance i dance after my shows he
like she'll do her show and then she
goes to dance class and then work does
dance for a couple of hours i'm like
what oh she'd be great she'd be great i
need to hang out with people like that
okay i'm like what oh my god it sounds
exhausting after a day i was working
myself i'm surprised yeah no she's
awesome though i didn't realize she
didn't so much but i saw a vegan show
and i was like she is is she tired like
because her she also has like two sets
of lungs when she sings
[Music]